bonjour à tous pour notre dernier
épisode consacré à notre gastronomie
régionale nous allons partir à la
rencontre du chef Christophe et chef
étoilé à Blois mais ce n'est pas tout de
suite dans les cuisines que nous allons
rencontrer mais au cœur de ce potager où
je me trouve actuellement qui a
seulement quelques centaines de mètres
de son restaurant fleur de Loire
[Musique]
bonjour Christophe et merci de nous
accueillir c'est important pour vous
d'être un chef jardinier bonjour ben en
fait en fait le jardin c'est mon
histoire c'est c'est là où tout a
démarré puisque puisque moi je suis issu
d'une famille agricole et finalement à
la ferme on a toujours eu un jardin que
entretenait justement ma grand-mère avec
le fumier des vaches voilà une terre qui
était hyper fertile et j'ai toujours
mangé de très bons légumes et quand je
me suis installé dans la région pour moi
c'était une évidence justement de
retrouver
nos racines avec ce goût avec ce que
pouvait nous apporter la terre donc
voilà on a commencé à gratouiller
gentiment avec avec 3000 mètres carrés
de terrain et puis aujourd'hui voilà une
fois Blois on a pu bénéficier justement
de ces terres en plein centre d'une
grande ville et on est passé en hectare
et demi et j'imagine que c'est pas du
tout incompatible avec le fait de
continuer à travailler avec des
producteurs en proximité exactement
l'idée c'est pas de c'est pas de
squeeziser justement nos producteurs
locaux l'idée vraiment de de faire des
petites variétés soit anciennes soit des
variétés que je vais ramener du monde
aussi voilà il y a vraiment une
multitude de choses qui se passent dans
le jardin qui sont assez sympathiques
alors justement on va les regarder d'un
peu plus près ce que vous cultivez dans
ce jardin et ce qui vous inspire en
cuisine avec ce reportage réalisé avec
Charlie Krief et Laurence Borie
observez
goûter
et cueillir Christophe et à leluxe de
venir remplir son panier directement
dans son potager le chef jette son
dévolu sur ses fèves
les fèves c'est superbe on a vraiment un
produit hyper végétal frais
et c'est vrai que c'est la période où on
peut aussi bien les manger crus que les
manger cuites et c'est fève ben voilà
c'est vinaigrette garniture peu importe
finalement la carte du
reste potager
[Musique]
nous sommes de retour avec Christophe et
cette fois-ci dans les cuisines de
fleurs de Loire la récolte au potager a
visiblement été très inspirante
inspirante parce que finalement on a des
couleurs on a des senteurs il y a des
textures donc voilà ça me donne envie de
cuisiner maintenant et donc là vous
allez nous préparer quelque chose de
très végétal parce que finalement notre
alimentation a évolué ces dernières
années et qu'aujourd'hui ben voilà sur
les grandes plaines de Beauce ben on se
retrouve à récolter aussi des pois
chiches et aujourd'hui ben voilà on va
essayer de la travailler avec avec cette
fleur de courgettes farci avec justement
cette farce qui est faite avec le pois
chiche donc c'est la base et puis
ensuite à l'intérieur on va rajouter de
la capucine parce que la capucine c'est
vraiment un produit qu'on adore par
dessus tout et puis ensuite on va on va
travailler sur trois petites textures
différentes autour du de la capucine
donc là bien entendu on a fait un comme
un petit coulis de Capucine donc on
blanchit les feuilles on les pulvérise
et on fait le coulis avec et ensuite le
pois chiche avec avec cette préparation
là on a fait le même principe qu'un
mollet le mollet c'est une préparation
mexicaine donc là on dépose voilà on
dépose nos mollets on vient déposer
notre fleur
autour bien entendu on va venir on va
venir mettre cette huile avec les
feuilles de capucine et les fleurs
donc voilà ma recette voilà ce que je
voulais vous présenter on a cet esprit
du mollet et là on a une recette qui est
superbe merci beaucoup Christophe et de
nous avoir accueillis dans votre
établissement votre page GT se termine
aujourd'hui merci de nous avoir suivi
tout au long de la semaine